We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two, David p.
Um, here's something that I get a lot.
Okay, and this is a caller who seems to have
built up an entire false reality in their
mind.
Take a listen to this.
Hey David, my name is Michael.
I'm a call in to you and Sam Cedar in Oswald's.
Michael Brooks for a little bit.
I feel like you're all kind of a little bit
nervous to the babies because I'm a conservative,
you know, I have different viewpoints.
Maybe I'm a little bit more convincing.
If you're open to a debate, open to open exchange
of ideas in the marketplace of ideas.
Uh, you know, feel free to, you know, give
me a call back.
What is this person talking about?
Right.
I mean it sadly, this type of thing is more
common than you might think.
I regularly get calls from people who believe
that there is a whole sort of thing going
on that I, I mean I have no clue who this
person is.
So what, what are the, what do they mean that
he gets the sense that I'm very nervous to
debate him because he's a conservative.
I mean it's just, uh, I don't, I genuinely
don't know where to feel bad and I don't want
to make fun of this person because some people
do call into the show who actually are mentally
ill and they're very disconnected from reality
and, and that's, you know, that's sad and
I don't want to be making fun of that.
But we've had people who believe I'm sort
of discretely sending them messages through
the show subliminally that there's a subtext
to what's going on.
Then I'm addressing the show to them specifically
that I'm calculating what to say in order
not to upset them or to upset them.
In some cases it's actually sad.
I don't know who this person is.
I don't know what they're talking about that
I and other hosts are nervous about debating
them.
If you want to challenge me about something,
we take live calls every week.
They aren't screened.
Any conservative can get on anytime they want
and challenged me about whatever they want.
I'm not nervous and I welcome back.
But, uh, I think that there's a sort of fantasy
land element to what's going on here and whether
it's a quirky or funny or sad or disturbing
or concerning, I don't really know.
But, uh, I don't know who you are and I'm
not nervous about debating you and I encourage
you to call in.
Absolutely.
Anytime.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
Um, things are not going well in the Dominican
Republic as a 10th American.
Has died.
We're going to talk about that as well as
what appears to be a bogus study related to
smart phones and the idea of sending astronauts
back to the moon by 2024 just four years old
way.
Is that possible?
Is it feasible?
All of those stories and more on the bonus
show today, sign up at www.joinpacman.com